Joe and gay hello and congratulations
I'd like to thank professor Shi Appa so
much for inviting me to your retirement
dinner and for letting me send my love
my video since I'm on vacation the week
of the big event I know you've done a
tremendous amount of good in your years
teaching writing at MIT in addition to
guiding students with their projects
you've demonstrated the way a working
writer lives his craft getting the job
done day after day after day as I should
know because I just checked and found
out that I have been your editor since
1997 and I'm luckier than MIT since as
far as I know you're not planning on
retiring from writing I hope that you
and Gaye are having a wonderful evening
full of people who love and value you
which you completely deserve
congratulations Joe and have a wonderful
retirement
hi Joe I'm really sorry that I can't be
at your retirement dinner and I really
wish that I could be there to give you a
hug and say best wishes on your
retirement since I can't I'll say it
from here Joe you're one of my favorite
writers you're one of my favorite
teachers and you're one of my favorite
people and I feel like it's a great loss
MIT that you're leaving them although
I'm sure that it's going to be great for
you to have more time for your writing
to MIT I'd like to say you guys are
losing a treasure I'm sure you already
know that and the only comfort that you
have is that you still will have Joe's
terrific works I'd recommend that if you
start missing him you go read oh say
graves or none so blind or the Hemingway
hoax or the forever war my very favorite
novel and one that I think about all the
time so you still have those works I'm
sorry you won't have Joe best wishes to
all of you and again I'm really sorry I
couldn't be there
bye Joe
hello Joe it's a great pleasure to be
able to talk to you I'm the occasional
this great celebration I'm proud of you
and as everyone else I want to say that
I had one of the greatest conversations
of my life with you at the convention
which I responded your query about my
well-being with the sentence well Joe my
whole life hurts a lot less now and and
I want to mention the Hemingway hopes
which is my favorite of all your books
so beautiful so complex and yet so clear
I cried at the last line
I just wanted to thank you because the
debt I owe you cannot possibly be
expressed or if it's expressed in words
it's expressed in the words that I've
written ever since then I had a story
this year that was a finalist on the
stoker ballot for what they referred to
it's long fiction that was published in
as amaz last fall I've landed on ballot
after ballot after ballot for my fiction
and I really appreciate that and I also
think that I teach fiction that's worth
more college and other places in part
because of you because I think you
instilled in me a kind of sense of you
have to pay it forward that you show
other people what you know you work with
other people you get other people
published you do everything you can for
them even quietly even bribing them
declaring you know staff and I taught
and clearing this this past summer I
taught the first week at San Diego and
loved it once again and feel like in a
way I've come full circle because of you
gone from being a student at Clarion to
having now taught at Clarion four times
so anyway I wanted to thank both of you
for everything for years and years of
friendship that doesn't need to be
repaid does it certainly I don't know
what else to say about that I love being
your friend I will continue to be your
friend even when you don't drink
anything anymore
and we're both sober I thank you for
everything and that's really about all I
have to say I think yeah so thanks I
hope both of you are having a really
good time and finally I just want to
note because the way this this computer
screen thing works you don't realize
that I'm in fact not wearing pants thank
you and good night
hey Joe happy retirement you may think
you're retiring so you'll have a lot
more time to sit in the Sun in a hammock
and play guitar but we're all hoping
that it means you'll have a lot more
time to write a lot more books and
stories Joe and gay oh my god
bestest the friends greatest of allies
and peerless of colleagues it's not the
same around here without you guys you
guys classed up the joint and really we
don't get as much Sun without the two of
you here we miss you so much
we miss you so much and I just can't
thank you enough for your friendship and
your kindness and I miss seeing your
faces I miss I miss you guys very much
and I just send you all my love yeah and
after all I ain't nobody around here
writing lines like he didn't tell me he
was from another world and I didn't tell
him I was from the future thank you so
much you guys